la troisième elle va concerner
l'écologie est elle va concerner le
gaspillage alimentaire nous avons michel
avec nous pour soir michel bonsoir merci
d'être là merci à vous michel vous avez
52 ans
vous êtes président cofondateur de hop
hop food
alors c'est quoi au food up août c'est
une association loi 1901 qui favorise le
don alimentaire directement entre
particuliers
c'est ça de façon totalement gratuite
exactement alors vous vous avez une
proposition oui et ça concerne bien sûr
ce que vous faites dans la ville alors
ma proposition est en forme de
provocation
moi je souhaiterais commettent une
amende à tous les particuliers qui comme
nous jettent des produits alimentaires
non entamés non périmés donc tout à fait
consommables plutôt que de les donner à
une association les données à leur
voisin où les données à travers
l'application code food moi je propose
de dire stop ça suffit
il ya 13 millions de personnes qui sont
en précarité alimentaire donc il ya
beaucoup de gens précarité alimentaire
d'un côté il ya beaucoup de gens des
particuliers qui gâche et qu'il faut
aucun effort donc disons stop et touche
aux portefeuilles et arrêtons d'être
complaisant avec ces particuliers qui
gâche de la nourriture complètement
consommables alors voilà michel je vais
donner quelques chiffres
merci pour conforter vos dires alors 10
millions de tonnes d'aliments
consommables vont à la poubelle chaque
année en france exactement cesse ça
correspond à 16 milliards d'euros en
décrire 16 milliards d'euros chaque
français jette environ un repas par
semaine à la poubelle il faut savoir
qu'un français sur cinq ne peut pas
manger trois repas par jour dont ces
gens vous dites c'est vrai que vous vous
proposez donc de toucher au portefeuille
de ceux donc qui qui gaspillent mais le
problème c'est comment on pourrait faire
parce que les et c'est compliqué de
voilà concrètement comment on pourrait
faire si vous voulez aujourd'hui comme
quelqu'un jette un mégot dans la rue il
peut avoir une amende
oui c'est quand même moins grave que tu
étais des produits alimentaires qu'on
pourrait consommer alors juste ici
autour d'agapes puisqu'on va pas tous
mais c'est gratuit berne alors la
question allait là c'est toi que des
comptes
mais comment voulez faire avec wanlease
l idée fabuleuse là mais comment voulez
faire vous allez pas m vous allez
permettre à canakkale à chaque poubelle
jeu tu vois encore une fois s'est arrêté
aux taxes et il faut éduquer donc voilà
il faut éduquer c'est ça
mais c'est la même chose pour l'instant
[Applaudissements]
il faut faire du sport mais c'est trop
tard c'est au tas il faut éduquer chez
les jeunes il faut apprendre n'a pas
jeté leur apprendre à faire du sport
voilà c'est l'éducation c'est pas taxées
c'est pour ça que c'est une amende si
non mais c'est pas la question de
l'application qui y seront viables et
pas une âme c'est s'il ya une leçon à
retenir de l'épisode des des gilets
jaunes c'est que l'écologie peut pas
être punitive parce que l'écologie
oui absolument ça doit être une écologie
persuasif plutôt qu une écologie
punitive vous allez braquer les gens en
plus effectivement c'est inapplicable
une police de la poubelle en belgique ça
se fait vous allez déjà agents à faire
monter en pente en taxes que nourrit
fonds qui font une enquête et qui vont
aller expliqué avant de mettre une
amende
ils vont pas mettre une amende comme ça
ils vont expliquer d'abord ils vont
faire la pédagogie et toucher au
portefeuille c'est juste signifié au
niveau national que stop ça suffit mais
yahia reine de la provoc h et autant de
vraies problématiques cela gaspillage
alimentaire ça c'est clair indéniable
après est ce que c'est la solution je ne
sais pas on voit on a par exemple dans
son réfrigérateur des produits qui vont
être périmés qu'on ne mange pas que ça
veut dire on va être taxés on va les
manger vite on s'étonnera l'obésité
d'après mme de l'obésité sur un petit
peu c'est la bonne solution
non mais si on fait quoi christine l
envie d'aller dans
voix 10 février fait ressortir à tous
les malades
non c'est parce que lui c'est en dehors
de devenir ce que veut dire le monsieur
il faut le donner aux six mois je
préfère donner aux essais mais il a dit
qu'il faut télécharger d'autres
applications au foot vous donnez vous
allez bien et les voisins qui sont
enregistrés dans l'application
j'entretiens du nautisme
c'est super je prends ça vous prend
quelques minutes allaient lui donner
c'est votre super c'est très simple est
ce que est ce que on peut quand même
développé cette prise de conscience
voilà que je t'ai aujourd'hui des
produits non périmés n'ont entamé les
accords d'alger opposés aux moyens voilà
c est michel je pense que ça tout le
monde est d'accord avec toi c'est normal
mais après il faut un électrochoc
ouais y eu une âme en voulaient les
électrocuter en plus de la même veine ça
vient violences à des gens méchants
comprendre sur le jean michel basquiat
mais nous aussi on le dit comme ça et
oui ils sont passés mans ça va ça
avancera pas je suis un peu d'allemand
avec michel vivoux avec le gary verchain
alimentaire est le seul gaspillage qui
montent comme ils s'appellent la
précarité alimentaire a eu l'arrivée par
deux qui s'appelle michel il faut il
faut quand même on est dans une
situation d'urgence
carrez veut dire en train d'édifier
exactions policières
michel à dire non seulement d'être
dissipées ce soir inclus d'iron man
amani saint ivy sujet sérieux michel
effectivement très et pillages
c'est énormissime et c'est pas que le
particulier qui oscille du stress
ouais bonjour j'ai fait une proposition
concrète michel et non lucien donc je
fais beaucoup et ce pour quoi vous allez
vers une écologie punitive alors qu'il
faut aller vers une écologie incitatives
positive et moi je fais une proposition
il faut qu'on travaille collectivement
et sur ses seins je la mettais dans la
boucle la grande distrib et l'industrie
alimentaire
si chaque citoyen ramène à la grande
distribution un moment donné ce que
gaspiller jusqu'à présent pourquoi on
n'aurait pas un système vertueux et des
jeunes qui sont en souffrance est
effectivement parfois un petit monde
d'achat une petite réduction sur les
courses qu'on va faire la prochaine fois
ça peut inciter les gens à être vertueux
mais dans une démarche positive
pourquoi vous êtes toujours sur la taxe
qui fait mal fait quelque chose qui
donne envie il faut donner envie envie
d'avoir à l'industrie agroalimentaire
ab devient distribution croyez moi ça
serait très vertueux et jeunes joueront
le jeu et michel je pense qu'il est
d'accord avec vous oui la grande
distribution il ya beaucoup de choses
qui ont été faites déjà une loi un halo
garraud la loi et 45000 sommes qui sont
plus cachés dans les cercles mais c'est
ailleurs monsieur garneau a reçu de viol
estimant donc il ya quarante tonnes d'un
côté saleh les cantines tout ce qui est
restauration collective ya beaucoup de
choses rien n'est fait côté particuliers
rien n'est fait sauter particulier
faisons le sens de taxer 54% du cash
bien sûr donc c'est à dire que y'a on
parle la grande distribution mais ce que
dit qu'on parle la conjointe de livres
dont on parle des restaurants on parle
jamais de nous et moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec le gilet jaune c'est
vrai que c'est important de mieux vivre
mais il ya des choses qui peuvent qui
dépendent de nous alors c'est pas
toujours les autres mais michel
quotidien le mieux vivre et l'écologie
de messieurs monsieur d'origine qu'est
ce que qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire à
michel là dessus on partage croit tous a
vraiment tout le monde
la volonté de lutter contre le
gaspillage alimentaire après vous savez
sans doute même mieux que nous parce que
vous avez étudié la chose dans le détail
qu'il ya différentes façons gaspiller
déjà on sait bien en tout cas quand on
est enfant les assiettes qui sont pas
finies et c'est bon ça toute façon on
peut rien faire d'autre que leur cycle
et éventuellement dans les circuits on
peut même produire du gaz
à partir des déchets recyclables mais on
peut pas on va pas le rendre à quelqu'un
on sait aussi qu'on peut éduquer ça moi
je pense qu'en effet c'est là la chose
le levier principal sur le fait de pas
acheté en surnombre on voit bien que
dans beaucoup de supermarchés on nous
pousse à acheter des choses
en fait en trop grande quantité les
acadiens world de 16 si on est une
famille nombreuse d'accord si on n'est
pas une famille nombreuse ça sert à rien
et aussi la date de péremption les d'une
semaine on va jamais mangé 16 yaourt a
toutefois tout seul en une semaine man
et ainsi de suite
ça c'est le vrai sujet il ya aussi la
loi dont vous avez parlé et c'est quand
même un petit peu intéressant d'en dire
un mot
c'est un député guillaume garot je le
dis d'autant plus il n'est pas du même
parti politique de moi il a travaillé
il a identifié le problème il a cherché
des solutions
il a fait une loi ça se fait pas en un
jour il a convaincu la majorité de la
beauté à l'époque et aujourd'hui on
regarde s'il est appliqué
c'est une boîte 2016 donc c'est pas
vieux et grâce à cette loi on a augmenté
de 22%
les dons des supermarchés les invendus
des supermarchés aux associations qui
font de la solidarité à l'égard de la
vidéo c'est un enjeu extrêmement
important aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya des
gens qui vont aux restos du coeur qui
vont à la banque alimentaire pour avoir
les aliments vraiment ce qui va leur
permettre de manger tous les jours donc
ça c'est un résultat intéressant et
c'est quand même le gros enjeu c'est que
les supermarchés et ça a été ces lois
qui contraint les supermarchés a passé
ses accords avec les associations de
solidarité nous était ok alors on a on a
une jeune fille dans le public qui
voudrait intervenir
relevez vous levez vous bonsoir pour ça
merci d'être là voilà alors on peut on
peut brancher nos micros la jeune fille
s'il vous plaît si ces deux petits
branchement à faire en fait oui alors
comment vous appelez leoni bonsoir leoni
voilà je vous interpelle parce que par
rapport aux fast-foods les grandes
enseignes
c'est parce qu'ils sont pas très
surveillée parce que nous on a le
rond-point du coeur on recolle de la
nourriture pour pouvoir donner aux
familles et aux personnes qui sont
manque de nourriture qu'ils n'ont pas
c'est les moyens par rapport au rang
duquel on voit que c'est toujours les
particuliers qui nous donne mais pas les
grandes enseignes parce qu'il préfère
jeter et quand nous on va dans les
grandes enseignes pour fouiller un peu
dans les poubelles pour pouvoir ramasser
soit on reçoit un un monde soit les
agent de sécurité nous mettre à la porte
vous voyez c'est plus compliqué çà çà çà
çà c'est vrai ça c'est vrai que sur le
fira ça se passe comme ça la raison et
c'est vrai qu'on n'en parlait des médias
monsieur mettez la chapelle aussi sur
les la nourriture pour nous empêcher de
calor coeur pour ça ça par exemple ça
c'est important de la javel sur les
produits c'est interdit sauf ici c'est
les poissons ou les fruits de mer parce
que là il ya des problèmes de sanitaires
mais moi je vous propose pourrait
étudier ça hein j'ai pas je dis pas
assez on va claquer les doigts demain
matin il ya monsieur il a développé une
application
on pourrait développer une application
pour que les citoyens les consommateurs
les clients des commerces quand ils
voient un supermarché qui déraille plus
tôt peut-être que de mettre une amende
aux particuliers par rapport à sa
poubelle que l'on puisse signaler aux
autorités
parce que c'est pas aux citoyens
évidemment de mettre une amende un
supermarché il signale aux autorités
pour que la loi soit appliquée parce que
la loi elle prévoit que ces pratiques là
sont interdites les européens la chine
n'ont plus le droit de jeter dans les
poubelles des aliments qui sont encore
valables ils doivent les donner à des
associations jusqu'avant la drogue à
roald oblige les supermarchés de plus de
400 mètres carrés à donner leurs
invendus alimentaire tissot sollicité
par des associations en échange d'une
baisse d'impôts en cas de refus les
supermarchés peuvent avoir une amende de
3750 euros par infraction et selon les
chiffres 95% des supermarchés donc
léonie concernés donnent désormais leurs
invendus à des associations
donc voilà pour certains supermarchés
sachez que donner aux associations n'est
pas assez rentable et il détourne aussi
la loi en a pas mal qui le font et c'est
peut-être ce de cela que vous parliez et
ça c'est vrai que forcément il faut être
plus répressifs envers ses supermarchés
qui ne respectent pas cette loi on a
quelqu'un dans le public juste on
n'avait non merci ne veut plus merci oui
alesi alesi madame je vais vous levez
vous bonsoir merci soir bonsoir
moi c'est natalia vous êtes vous n'êtes
pas une amie de bilal le coiffeur si
nous à quoi dans la vie et natalia on
parle de gaspillage et moi ce qui m'a
choqué parce que ben vous savez comme
tous ceux qui ont des enfants va au mcdo
et moi ce qui m'interpelle c'est qu' un
minuteur vous savez qui met en fait
quand une commande qui est passé pour un
hamburger est souvent cité que c'est
dépassé c'est souvent dépassés y jette
devant nous il ya un énorme gaspillage
dans les fast-foods et ça faut vraiment
faire quelque chose parce qu' on puisse
parler ne le donne pas aux associations
et bayal la javel ou à douala est pareil
on prend une amende si rex à récupérer à
ce que 10 à gâteaux pour la c1 c'est
très peu contrôlées est ce que c'est
possible d'avoir plus de contrôle
à ce niveau là monsieur le ministre oui
on a d'ailleurs décidé récemment de
renforcer les contrôles sur les fast
food enfin les chaînes de restauration
rapide qui ne respectent pas la loi
sur cet aspect mais aussi sur un autre
aspect qui est l'obligation de recycler
les déchets de trier et de recycler les
déchets si vous regardez sur les boîtes
en carton se marquer déchets recyclables
et tout va dans la même poubelle donc
toute façon et rija risque pas d'être
recyclés donc avec brune poirson qui est
secrétaire d'état auprès de moi et qui
travaille sur les questions de lutte
contre le gaspillage et de recyclage on
a commencé des opérations coup de poing
en allant directement dans des à la
sortie du du mcdonald's burger king ou
d'un autre un jeu pointe pas du doigt
reef hotel ou tel mais on va c'est quand
même une légalement week également on
obligé non il n'existe plus c'est bien
ça vient vous y allez pas mais en
l'occurrence attendez on va voir ce
qu'on pense des téléspectateurs
etes-vous pour ou contre m une amende
aux particuliers qui font du gaspillage
montant des 1500 votes contre à 68% pour
à 32%
je pense que oui mais voilà c'est pas si
mal